hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen in today's video I'm
gonna be talking about the potential
risk of all of that disinfecting and
sanitizing that a lot of us have been
doing for the past few months and
whether or not this has any impact on
our microbiome and overall health now
before we get started I want to express
that this information is of course for
entertainment and educational purposes
only and you should always speak to a
doctor and dietitians and healthcare
professionals about your unique
healthcare needs also by the time that
this video goes live or just into the
future there may be some updated
research so I will try to do my best to
update the description with that
information okay
so unless you have been sleeping through
2020 so far there is a worldwide
shortage of sanitizing products
available for purchase at just about
every store in North America I already
talked about safe protocols for cleaning
groceries and your take out in the age
of koban 19 so if you missed that video
you can check it out right here but a
lot of people have been questioning the
potential risks of the hyper vigilant
state of sanitation that we are all
currently living in now before we can
get into the nitty-gritty of whether or
not using bleach is safe and healthy we
need to talk about the concern of these
disinfectants on our microbiome a lot of
concern around over sanitation can be
traced back to what we know as the
hygiene hypothesis which is basically
correlated the rise in industrialization
and sanitation practices with the
incidence of allergies and autoimmune
diseases like type 1 diabetes asthma
Crohn's disease multiple sclerosis and
inflammatory bowel disease now back in
the 1980s an epidemiologist named dr.
Strawn found that the more children in a
family or home the lower the risk of
autoimmune diseases and allergies he
proposed that the decreased incidence of
infection early on in life
typically passed through unhygenic
contact between siblings could be the
cause of developing autoimmune
complications later on in life
now the term hygiene hypothesis isn't so
great and a lot of scientists have
thought to have it changed because
personal sanitation practices are one of
our first lines of defense against
harmful bacteria or viruses so no one is
ever telling you to stop washing your
hands in this pandemic or like ever the
concern instead is when these sanitation
practices are taken to an extreme or
directed at situations that are not
actually harmful significantly limiting
children's healthy exposure to the
microbes aka bacteria in their
environment more recent research has
taken the foundation on which the
hygiene hypothesis was laid on and
developed clear guidelines and
recommendations surrounding sanitation
and hygiene which has resulted in what
we now know of as targeted hygiene so
evidence now suggests that a combination
of strategies should be integrated into
young children's lives in order to best
protect their microbiomes from
complications later on in life these
strategies include vaginal childbirth if
possible breastfeeding if possible
increasing social exposure through
things like sports social interactions
and outdoor activities having pets like
cats or dogs in the home as well as
appropriate antibiotic use targeted
hygiene is where risky activities like
touching raw meat or using the washroom
should be followed with proper hygienic
practices but at the same time playing
outside in the soil petting the family
dog and sharing toys with peers should
be encouraged targeted hygiene allows
for the protection against harmful
pathogens while also promoting and
allowing for the healthy spread of
microbes between peers family members
and the environment allowing for the
introduction of such microbes is so
important for the establishment of a
healthy immune system which for the most
part is trained by the age of four now
can we improve our microbiome later on
in life there are some strategies that
can be utilized in youth and adulthood
in order to develop a robust mic
by ohm including consuming a sufficient
amount of fruits and vegetables whole
grains and getting in our exercise
research research has linked the
Mediterranean diet which is a diet rich
in lots of fruits and vegetables whole
grains healthy fats - significant
increases in beneficial microbes in our
gut therefore if you're concerned about
your microbiome transitioning to a more
balanced and whole food diet may be a
good place to start other strategies
include having pets in the house and
living close to Edgar culture or green
space
bottom line healthy exposure to safe
microbes from our environment and each
other
is not a bad thing in fact it's a very
good thing
however these studies are referring to
non pathogenic microbes not Cova 19 the
key is to recognize low risk situations
and high risk situations and no one to
employ enhanced cleaning and sanitation
washing your hands after grocery
shopping in covin 19 times necessary
Purell in your kids hands the second
that they pet the family dog not
necessary okay so now let's talk about
all of those disinfectant wipes Lysol
sprays bleach sanitizers etc and how
they impact our microbiome and health
while the evidence here is very
preliminary and done primarily with
animals that are fed a diet with these
chemicals in it there is early research
to suggest that when or if antimicrobial
enter into our body if not handled
properly it may affect our microbiome
much of the research has focused on
compounds called triclosan and
triclocarban now triclosan is an
antimicrobial agent that is added to a
lot of household cleaning supplies as
well as soaps toothpastes and some
cosmetics the FDA is continuing to
monitor this chemical and is aware of
studies being done to test its safety
for human use they also did ban the use
of both of these chemicals in consumer
soaps back in 2016 indicating that they
recognized a safety concern with over
exposing one cells to them
one study in animals of course found
that zebrafish which were fed a diet
containing Trikke listen experienced an
alteration in their gut microbiota after
only four days another study on humans
found an altered gut flora in children
who were frequently exposed to household
disinfectants these children were then
linked to have a higher body weight by
the time that they were three years old
when compared to children who were not
exposed to heavy home use of
disinfectants having said that this is
just correlation and what we don't know
is if the families who chose greener
methods of cleaning ate healthier or of
higher socioeconomic status were more
likely to be breastfed or had access to
the outdoors attributing to a completely
different outcome in their microbiome
and ultimately their weight another
thing to know is that while this study
did find a difference in the microbial
community composition of the children
who are exposed to the non eco friendly
chemical products they did not find any
changes in the microbial richness or
diversity this essentially means that
there were more microbes introduced
which were linked to weight gain and or
negative health effects but there was no
negative impact on the already existing
microbial community that is the existing
type of pre-existing microbes bottom
line I'll be honest the research in this
area is not great period and we need a
lot more of it but the good news is that
of all of the links between Hygiene and
the microbiome researchers believe that
being too clean in our own homes
is one of the weakest and most
unsupported notions perpetuated by the
hygiene hypothesis it's believed that if
over sanitizing the home contributed to
an increase in allergies or autoimmune
diseases it would be a relatively small
contribution this is because
microbiological studies have confirmed
that regular cleaning habits while
decreasing pathogens and dust
temporarily do not have a sustained
effect on microbes in the home one
review article claimed that the idea
that we could create sterile homes
through excessive cleanliness
implausible as fast as microbes are
removed they are replaced via dust and
air from the outdoor environment and
commensal microbes shed from our human
body and our pets and contaminated foods
brought into the home now what about
these cleaning chemicals and our
respiratory health which is obviously a
pretty hot topic right now in the Cova
19h well I did find one study that found
that people who worked as cleaners or
frequently cleaned their homes with
chemicals particularly aerosols and
sprays had decreasing rates of lung
function other studies have linked
increased asthma rates to cleaning
workers and suggest that preventive
measures be put in place when using
chemical cleaners especially when it
comes to cleaning disinfectant sprays
bleach and ammonia now are these
chemicals safe to use in pregnancy
probably in moderation if the conditions
are right a large study which was
published in 2018 concluded that
chemical use while pregnant resulted in
an increased risk of the child in utero
developing wheezing and/or asthma but
while the media had a total frenzy on
this it's important to note that there
was actually no significant relationship
found between chemical exposure and lung
function tests and no asthma cases were
actually ever confirmed by a medical
professional in response to these
misconceptions the United Kingdom
National Health Service issued a
comprehensive statement that parents
should not be overly concerned with
their cleaning regimes so long as
they're really following general safety
protocols by ensuring rooms are
adequately ventilated and precautions
are taken to protect one's self from
touching and inhaling those fumes so
wearing a mask and wearing gloves the
American Pregnancy Association also
ensures that cleaning products including
properly diluted bleach are safe to use
while pregnant but they too also
recommend wearing gloves ventilating the
room and reading the labels prior to use
or even better getting an
now what are safe cleaning compounds for
combating bad pathogens like Copa 19 so
the Environmental Protection Agency EPA
has a comprehensive list of
disinfectants or sanitizers that are
approved to kill viruses like Cova 19
which are generally grouped as
quaternary ammonium compounds aka quat's
like Lysol heavy duty disinfectant
iodine base sanitizers acid and onyx an
atty tzer's hydrogen peroxide sanitizers
like Clorox thymol which is a natural
and botanically based disinfectant or
alcohol AKA ethanol which you can easily
buy in semi percent ethanol bottles
choosing eco-friendly alternatives to
sanitizers is of course an option as
most popular brands now have a green
alternative for slightly higher price so
I'm gonna leave a link below to some of
the EPA approved safe products but an
example that I have personally seen on a
lot of shelves is seventh-generation
products
note that homemade products like baking
soda and vinegar or lemon juice are
totally fine for cleaning your home but
are not germicide and therefore they do
not kill germs well enough to actually
sanitize as for those who rely on
essential oils as a sanitizer of choice
caution should be taken with this method
of cleaning in order to avoid viruses
such as koban 19 well we are starting to
see more research surrounding the
potential benefits of essential oils for
cleaning it is definitely still lacking
one review found that while some oils
have shown antimicrobial properties
their effectiveness does rely on the
individual oils chemical constituents
the quantity of these compounds as well
as the particular properties of the
bacteria it's aiming to kill so
basically some oils may have an effect
on some bacteria but an individual oil
will need to be matched with a specific
microbe in order for the disinfectant
properties to actually take place these
studies were also held in vitro within a
lab and have failed to provide any clear
mechanism of action
leading the researchers to worry about
reproducibility and just the accuracy of
their findings the bottom line is that
more research is definitely needed as
well as more just actual clinical trials
in order to create any clear and
scientifically validated recommendations
for placing your household sanitizer
with essential oils especially in Cova
19 times this is simply because FDA
approved sanitizers kill up to 99.9% of
germs which is something that essential
oils cannot yet claim now what about
soap can it be used on my counters and
high-touch surfaces in place of a
chemical disinfectant so hand washing as
rudimentary as it may seem protects us
from viruses like Copa 19 because it has
the potential to inactivate the virus
before effectively washing it down the
sink
if the hand-washing is done properly and
for 20 seconds in the same way that soap
attaches to the oil and dirt on our
hands to wash the debris down the sink
so to does it attach the molecules that
are responsible for infecting us with
coronavirus because of this the most
effective easy and sensible way to break
the chain of infection is with proper
and regular hand washing this can be
done with any regular soap as there's
actually no additional benefit to using
an antibacterial soap if proper
hand-washing procedures are actually
followed now I have to say an
antibacterial sanitizer or disinfectant
is still the number one recommendation
for cleaning high-traffic surfaces in
your home because they can kill 99.9% of
germs in seconds
but if cleaning supplies are short in
your area soapy water and some elbow
grease can still do the trick following
the same logic as with proper hand
washing surfaces can be scrubbed with
soapy water for at least 20 seconds and
then thoroughly rinsed off in order to
ward off germs and viruses so bottom
line how can we safely clean in a
pandemic we know that being exposed to
an array of microbes is important but we
also know that not
acting ourselves from harmful pathogens
like Koba 19 can be detrimental to our
health
I'm sure this point will be driven home
due to the current situation but the
belief that children must be exposed to
harmful microbes in order to build a
robust immune system is simply not true
this has never actually being the case
targeted hygiene is a risk assessment
directed at sorting out the Huayra
situations where the pathogenic
transmission is more likely from
low-risk situations where microbes are
not harmful and/or there is not a high
risk of exposure so to start there are
key times when practicing hygiene in
order to break the chain of infection is
really important these high-risk times
include during food handling while
eating with hands after using the
washroom after coughing or sneezing into
your hands or nose blowing after
handling soiled or dirty linen after
handling or disposing of garbage caring
for animals and caring for an infected
family member who is vomiting coughing
and/or having diarrhea so should you
stress about your temporary uptick and
hyper-vigilant cleaning rituals I mean
not necessarily as long as you're taking
the precautions to reduce your risk of
excess chemical exposure like
ventilating the space really well or
wearing a mask and gloves also I do
suggest taking the time to recognize
which situations are high-risk and which
are not I mean perhaps the excessive
cleaning is not necessarily called for
if there hasn't been exposure to a
potentially risky situation outside or
inside the home so on that note that is
all for today folks as always if you
like this video please give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below if
you have any microbiome related
questions I love talking about the
microbiome subscribe to the channel and
I will see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]
you